Now that we've got our car set up, let's go ahead and look at adding the light and camera
controls to the UMG.
So we'll jump back into the editor here.
We want to now create a new UMG for this toggling on and off the lights.
So we'll go to our UMG folder down underneath the blueprints folder.
You can see that we've got our display widget from the top and you'll see that we've got
some panel widgets here, but we've got the the HUD UMG, which is the main element.
And if I, you don't need to go ahead and double click this, but if you look, we've got the
individual panel UMGs here that were created outside of this UMG here, this left and right
panel, these left and right panels here.
So what we'll do is if I just close this again, I'll create a new panel here to add to the
main UMG HUD.
So we can just go right click, user interface, widget blueprint, and we'll just select user
widget here.
And you could call this light cam underscore UMG, some kind of naming convention that makes
sense to you for what the purpose is.
Again, just underscore UMG is good at the end there because then that kind of tags the
asset type as well.
So I'm just going to double click this open.
The size is just as desired, but what we would want is a size box to make sure that once
we've got the desired size, we can add everything in there.
So I'm just going to type size box at the top, size box appears here.
I'm just going to drag this here.
So we've got a size box here and then we want to get a canvas panel underneath this size
box next.
So we'll get a canvas panel and there we go.
So we've got the canvas panel and now what we can do is we can build the background image
from this and then also have a horizontal box with the two different images that we
want to add for both the light and the camera.
So we've got the canvas panel here.
We also want a horizontal box.
So we'll add a horizontal box.
So we've got this here and then you'll see this box here, which we can shape as desired.
Then we'll add a border for the images.
So we want a border for here.
So we'll type in border and then after border, we want an image.
So again, it's kind of just stacking these things.
Image if I can spell that correctly.
So we've got image.
We drag and drop the image down there.
And so what we actually want for the image is the light icon.
So we want to make sure we find this light icon in our content browser.
So I'm going to go back into my map here.
I believe it might be in materials, textures.
Yeah, so we've got our light on and off here.
So this is what we want.
So I think we want the icon background for this section here.
So we'll pull that into the UMG, go to image, and then we just want to override the image,
which should be in the brush setting here.
And then we'll just plug that icon in there.
And you can see that the sizing isn't quite correct yet, but let's just get all the functionality
set up and then we can go into detailing everything.
So we've got the icon there and we also want the camera button that we want to click to
go through.
So I'm just going to select this horizontal box.
Again, just the ordering of these things needs to be specific.
Of course, you can design it however you want, but the ordering for this example makes sense
in the structure that we're following.
So let's just go to the horizontal box and type a button now.
So I want to drag and drop a button onto the horizontal box.
And now we've got a button here and now we want an image for the button.
Now I'm just going to, because we've now got multiple things going on, I'm just going to
start renaming things as well, just as I go.
So button here, I'm going to right click and rename.
Again, F2 can do that as well.
And then I'm going to call this camera BTN for button.
Then the border here, we'll call this the light border.
So I'm just going to rename this light border and then you want the light image here.
So we'll just call this light image.
So we need another icon for our camera button.
So let's go in and add an image here.
Let's go back to our content.
And then we just want to select the arrow, go back into our UMG and then go to find an
image.
So image, drag and drop this over the button and the image is going to be like that.
So as a quick summary, we should have something that looks like this.
So we've created a new UMG.
We've got the size box here, we've got the canvas panel and the background.
So just making sure your structure looks something similar to this.
So we'll go ahead and update the size in here.
We'll make sure the icon is then the correct off light icon and then move to the next step.
So let's jump back in our editor.
And first, we just want to make sure that we fill out the correct boxes.
So we'll go to the camera button, click fill, and then also the light button and click fill.
So we've got one to one sizing going on here.
And then also the light image that we mentioned, we now just want to make sure this is the
correct off light button.
So let's just check that that's working.
So that looks good.
And then I think that's pretty much it.
So I think we can go ahead and save and move to the next section.
So we'll just compile, save and then move to the next section.
Two detailing settings that we need to do before moving on, which I just forgot about
is if we go to our light border, we just want to go back into our content and add that background
image here, the icon.
So we'll go back into our UMG on the light border, we will just go down to our brush
settings.
So under appearance, brush, I will plug that in.
So we have the nice looking background that we wanted.
And then also this camera icon just needs making a little bit bigger.
So on image size under brush, we'll just go to 128.
Maybe that can be 256 by 256.
Always trying to keep power of two icons where possible.
So I'm going for 256.
Again, it depends on the size that you've gone for here.
But we should essentially end up with something that looks a little bit like this.
So again, the style doesn't need to be spot on.
But again, just keeping in mind the hierarchy here and then some kind of visual representation.
We'll be moving on to the blueprints now, which is actually the main functionality.
So this is all mainly aesthetic at the moment.
But hopefully, your results should look something a little bit like this.
So again, we'll compile and save and then move into the graph now.
So if we go to the graph, you'll see that we have this pre construct node already in
place.
This is what we want to use for the display vehicle blueprints.
So we'll drag out from pre construct.
And what we'll do is we'll type in get all actors.
And then we want to select this top option, get all actors of class.
And then what we'll do is on the class to select, we want to get that vehicle that's
in our map, which is the display vehicle.
So if I just find the display vehicle, I can do that.
And then what I'll do is actually have created the array version here.
So I'll actually get all actors of class, get actor of class.
That's the one that I want.
So get actor of class.
So just get actor of class.
All actors will return an array, which would still give us a similar result.
But because we know we've only got one in the scene, just make sure it's a get actor
of class.
And then what we'll do is we'll drag off this blue pin and promote it to a variable and
just call it maybe display.
And you can see on the left hand side here, I'm typing in the reference, but display vehicle
ref something like that.
I always add ref to the end of my actor references just to make sure I know that it's an actor
reference, but there's some kind of name like that.
You'll notice that I didn't put a space between display vehicle.
And because I gave vehicle a capital V and ref a capital R, you'll see that actually
spaces the name, which is quite nice.
You don't need to actually add a space into your reference variable reference name as
long as it's got a capital letter.
So that's just a nice, nice tip to move forward.
So on construct, which essentially just means when we're making this UMG, I want to find
this display vehicle again, just remembering to plug this display vehicle reference into
there and then we want to get the reference.
So again, we'll compile and save whenever working with blueprints, especially just get
into the habit of compiling and saving and then we'll move to the next section.
And then what we can do is we can go back into our designer and we want to get the light
border and what we want to do is we essentially want to know whether the light has been essentially
edited.
So we'll scroll down to the bottom here again, selecting our light border and we want to
find the on button, button mouse down here.
So if we click bind, we can just create a binding here.
You should have whatever you named your light border.
If you named it light border, you should see on light border mouse button down and that's
essentially what we're looking for.
And we're just going to plug in some code here.
I'm just going to left mouse, drag these pins.
I'm going to hold down alt and left click on the executable just to break that pin.
So I'm going to first create a new Boolean value.
So under variables, I'll just add a new variable and we'll call this is light on.
So I normally put B at the start of my Boolean because then that indicates it's a Boolean
and I'll put B is light on question mark.
And then what I'll do is I'll hold down control on my keyboard and left mouse drag to actually
get the variable.
If you just don't click anything on your keyboard and left mouse drag, it'll ask you whether
you want to get or set it.
So you can also do it that way.
This time I'm going to select set.
So I'm going to drag that in and click set.
Instead of holding down control to get, you can actually hold down alt to set.
So we need one get, one set, and there's multiple ways that you can add that.
I'm going to drag this in here and I'm going to drag off this bool here and type not.
So we want a not Boolean, which will be at the top here.
So not Boolean.
So is light not on?
That's what I essentially want to know.
Is the light not on?
And then we can just plug that in there because it's just going to flip it essentially.
If it's not on, it's going to be on.
If it's on, it's going to be not on essentially.
So next we want to get our display vehicle reference.
So I'm going to hold down control and drag in here.
And then we created a scene component called light holder.
I believe it was.
Let's just check what we, what we name this in a vehicle.
Yeah.
Light holder.
So what we want to do is we want to get the light holder.
Let's just see where this is.
If we childed it.
Oh, let's see.
Let's see what we've got here.
Default scene route.
Let's see if we need to get the default scene route.
Let's just make sure we're getting this correctly.
So we've got our display vehicle.
We've got our display vehicle ref.
I'm just going to compile this.
And go back to here.
Let's check this out.
So let's just remove any binding errors to our light board.
Maybe I've gone in and selected a wrong button somewhere.
Next to brush, it's got an unbound value here.
So I'm just going to, that shouldn't be on yours.
I may have just clicked that by accident.
Let's see.
Now I can compile, save, light holder.
I think what may have happened here is if we look at this display
vehicle reference, it's just actor.
So if I go back into my designer here, back into my graph,
I'll come out of this function into the event graph.
You'll see that this actor here.
So that's not correct.
So it should actually be display vehicle.
I'm not sure why it's not done display vehicle.
But what I'll do is I'll go back into my graph.
Sorry for clicking around here.
I'll go to my light board.
I'm just going to delete this variable for now.
I'll go back to my event graph.
I'm going to delete this display vehicle.
I'm going to delete it from here as well.
Again, if yours says display vehicle there,
that's the correct thing.
So I'm just going to compile and save.
And now I'm going to call this display vehicle.
I'll probably just give it a slightly different name.
So I'm not going to add ref there.
And I'm just going to set that.
So you can see now that it's display vehicle.
So that's strange that it was actor.
Should be display vehicle.
If yours was actor, definitely redo that.
If it's display vehicle, then you've done it correctly.
And we'll just compile and save.
Now let's go back into our light boarder.
Now let's grab our display vehicle
by holding down Control.
Now we should be able to find this light holder.
So let's see.
Now we've got light holder.
If we scroll down to the bottom,
the variables are going to be at the bottom there.
So get the light holder.
That's what we want it to see.
And we'll just set the visibility here.
So set visibility.
And because the lights are childhood to this scene,
they'll take on the visibility command,
which is a nice kind of clean way of doing it.
If we hadn't added this scene route,
so in our display vehicle,
you don't need to flip back and forth,
but I'm just showing you.
If you see the scene component,
we've got two lights added to this scene component.
So if we change the visibility here,
it changes the visibility on any of the children,
which is a nice little optimization.
But we could have got spotlight R,
got spotlight L, opposite way around,
and then just set visibility on both.
But because we do it on the scene route,
it actually applies it globally,
which is to its children, which is quite nice.
So we've got this.
We need to get our light boarder.
So we didn't actually make it a variable before.
So let's go back into our designer.
On our light boarder,
we just want to select is variable at the top there.
Again, compile, save,
just getting to that habit of doing that.
So is variable is now ticked.
And so now we have the light boarder variable down here.
Again, I'm holding down control on my keyboard.
I'm gonna set the brush color here.
So set brush color.
And then with the brush color,
I'm going to select.
So I'm gonna drag off this blue pin here and type select.
So I want it to actually do a select color option here.
So we've dragged off the darker blue pin, select,
and then we'll just do like maybe a deeper gray color here,
and then maybe a whiter color here or something like this.
Just something that indicates a change of color.
And then I'm gonna drag the Beers light on,
holding down control and add that there.
So it's just essentially gonna set the visibility
and set the brush color there.
And we want to plug in the return node here.
And then we want to right click and type in handled.
So we just want to make sure it's been handled
by the event reply.
So we'll find this handled option here,
and we'll just drag that into there.
So that's essentially what we have set up.
And now we want to compile and save,
and then move on to the next section.
Now we actually want to toggle the light image
so we can change these icons.
You know, these ones that we have here,
light on and light off,
that's what we want to actually now toggle.
So I'm gonna go back into my UMG.
I want to find my light image.
So we go to our light image here,
and now we want to bind the icon.
So we want to create a binding here.
So we actually want to set the light icon, sorry.
So what we'll do instead of get image brush,
we'll just rename this over here.
So I'm just gonna right click the get image brush.
I'm gonna rename this to set light icon.
Which makes way more sense as a variable name,
as a function name.
So essentially we want to set the icon base
if the light is on.
So let's hold down control and bring in this Boolean here.
And then from the return value,
what we want to do is we want to drag off and say,
make brush from texture,
which is this bottom element here.
Now, whatever values you used in the width and height,
so let's just go back into the designer.
Whatever size you used here,
if it was 128, I've just got 32 here,
which has filled out the space.
But again, if you've set this to 128,
like we did 256 here,
whatever these X and Y values are,
that's what we want to override here.
So I'm just gonna go back into my graph.
I'm going to name these 32,
but if you've used 128, 256, et cetera,
you can plug those in there.
And then we just want to do another select,
dragging off this texture section.
And then you'll see that by default,
this select does not have this Boolean connector here.
But what we can actually do is if we just drag that
into the green pin anyway, it'll change it to a Boolean.
So that'll hook in nicely there.
And then the false is going to be the light on icon.
So let's go back into here, select light on
in our content browser and plug that in there.
And then true, if we go back into our browser,
we'll select off and then go back into there
and select that like that.
Then compile and save.
And that'll be our function for updating the texture
on when we hover over it.
Now we want to go back into our main UMG
and add this light cam UMG or whatever we've referred to it.
I'm just going to save everything
just to make sure everything's up to date.
I can go back into my UMG folder
and I'm going to open the main hood UMG now.
So these are all user created widgets.
So we want to search the panel that we've created
in this user widgets section.
So you can see a light cam UMG, which is one I created,
whatever you named your UMG,
the one that we called here, update that.
So if I just drag that down here,
you'll see that I can move this
into the real estate that I want.
Again, the sizing is probably a little bit too big here,
but I can change that sizing and positioning.
So I'm just going to move across this position
and maybe bring it down a bit.
Again, it's probably a little bit too big.
We want to scale it down by 50% maybe,
but that'll do for now.
So I'll just make sure, I'm not sure if that impacts it,
but I just want to make sure that box is covering it.
I assume it's to detect the input there.
So I'm just going to compile and save.
And so at least we've now added it to our user creation menu.
Now, once it's compiled and saved,
if we just jump back into our map here
and then just press Alt and P,
you'll see that it comes up.
You'll see that we've got some kind of hovering
going on here.
And if I click the light on off,
you'll see that the light is going on and off.
Now from that, I noticed that the lights weren't turning
on and off and also the icon was back to front.
So let's just jump in there and fix that.
So under the Lightcam UMG, in the graph
and then in our border mouse down function,
we just want to make sure that visibility is the bull.
So yeah, that's all correct.
And then, yeah, so we just missed this bull here,
propagate to children.
So let's just make sure we go in and compile
and save that and test it out.
So when we click, okay, the lights are turning on and off now.
And now obviously the icon is back to front
based on that variable.
So I'm just going to go ahead
and change around those bullion values.
So I'm going to go back into my UMG.
I'm going to set light icon.
What I might do is just say, not here.
This is kind of a little cheat
and you could technically switch around on and off together.
But let's just see if this works
because that'll be the quick way to do it.
Yeah, so off, on, on, off.
So there we go.
Everything's working and now let's move on to our cameras.